a man in the United Kingdom
has just launched a terrible physical
assault on the king of of England
King Charles III
but because the man who attacked him
is very polite like all British people
he didn't attack him with a gun he
didn't attack him with a knife he didn't
punch him
he threw some eggs at him
you can see in the clip it's on BBC this
actually gives me a lot of respect for
King Charles the guy throws an egg and
Charles this just extraordinarily
dignified stuffy old British man just
kind of gently looks to his side as the
eggfuls doesn't blink doesn't move
doesn't Flinch at all and the guy keeps
throwing eggs at him terrible arm by the
way it doesn't hit him once but Charles
he doesn't duck this wasn't like George
Bush with the shoe in Iraq where he's
kind of ducking the shoes he just stands
there
and the eggs keep flying and Charles
just keeps you know wherever you're
shaking hands in the line it's very very
dignified and it's good it really makes
me think
one
Charles is a lot manlier and more virile
than I think people including myself
would have given him credit for but two
that's dignity
you know American politics not very
dignified whatever else you want to say
about American politics
it is not conducive to dignity
and it would be nice to have a little
bit of dignity just a little little
smidge of it as much as we can possibly
have in this kind of eccentric country
of ours when you look at Charles doing
that you think that's
that that's quite nice I actually rather
I rather like that I wish that we had
people who would stand up straight and
not flinch you know and kind of keep on
keep on keeping on keep a stiff upper
lip as the British have now for the man
who egged King Charles uh this man's
punishment
is I'm not joking he's a 23 year old man
Patrick felwell his punishment is that
he can he can no longer carry eggs in
public
just like that one of life's simple Joys
taken away from him that's right
no longer can he carry eggs
in public but otherwise he's basically
off the hook it's fine no big deal
in this case
really you would have to say the
punishment fits the crime you throw eggs
at the king you lose your egg privileges
that's very good one of the problems in
the American justice system right now is
that the punishments don't seem to fit
the crime if you are a BLM rioter and
you threaten people's lives and you Loot
and you steal and you pillage and you
burn and you throw Molotov cocktails
you don't get punished at all
you get maybe a little slap on the wrist
if that Kamala Harris bails you out of
jail and then you go right back into the
street do the same thing you get
encouragement actually for your crimes
from the the libs but if you're a
conservative who let's say shows up to
the capital rotunda on the day that
they're certifying the election and you
have a horn hat on and maybe you take
some selfies with a lectern in the in
the Rotunda and maybe I don't know you
crack a coarse light
at the Capitol you'll be thrown in
solitary confinement your life will be
ruined
the feds will go after you with
everything they've got forget about
January 6th for a second if you have the
audacity to say that you don't want your
kid to be transgendered in the third
grade you will be called a domestic
terrorist you will be investigated by
the federal government you'll be called
a fascistic threat to our sacred
democracy
it's a place where in
in neither case for the left or for the
right the punishments don't fit the
crimes
the the leftists need to be punished
much more harshly and the conservatives
currently are being punished far too
harshly
though there is there is a case here
that that just came out and no one's
really reporting on this but I think
they should speaking of people connected
to prince Andrew quite a segue
one of Jeffrey Epstein's Associates was
accused of doing all the creepy sex
stuff with the underage girls and he was
accused by the main accuser of Virginia
giuffrey
and he the whole time maintained his
innocence he denied he had anything to
do it and nobody believed him I believed
him actually and I gave him the benefit
of the doubt because I know him
personally and I I just thought he was
telling the truth that would be Alan
dershowitz the famed Harvard Law
Professor Alan dershowitz was and to say
Epstein associate is really actually
overstating it he was he was Epstein's
lawyer and every man is entitled to a
defense in this country and Alan
dershowitz has defended some of the
worst people on Earth he that's his job
that's his role in the justices he
defended OJ and so he defended Jeffrey
Epstein
he said I wish I never met Jeffrey
Epstein but every man's entitled to
offense and I was his attorney and I
don't regret it I don't regret being his
attorney
but when he was accused of doing weird
sex stuff with Virginia jewfrey he said
I didn't do it I didn't do it I have
never engaged in sexual misconduct you
know for all my other sins that's not
something I've ever done this woman is
mistaken it's not true she maintained
that it was true well
just this week she dropped her lawsuit
she dropped it again she dropped and the
allegations against Alan dershowitz she
said I have long believed that I was
trafficked by Jeffrey Epstein to Alan
dershowitz however I was very young at
the time it was very stressful and
traumatic environment and Mr dershowitz
has from the beginning consistently
denied these allegations I now recognize
I may have made a mistake in identifying
Mr dershowitz this litigation has been
very stressful and burdensome for me and
my family and we believe it is time to
bring it to an end and move on with our
lives
now some people who are more cynical or
skeptical they'll look at this and say
ah but dershowitz just paid her off
but dershowitz says he did not pay her
off he says that no no money has been
exchanged here
she is dropping the allegations and then
dershowitz says as I've said from the
beginning I never had sex with with Miss
jewfrey uh
I have nevertheless come to believe that
at the time she accused me she believed
what she said Miss jewfrey is to be
commended for her courage in now stating
publicly that she may have been mistaken
about me she suffered much at the hands
of Jeffrey Epstein
and so so
now Alan dershowitz is dropping his
allegations that David boys engaged in
an extortion plot
and in supporting words right it was
this whole complex thing they were all
just dropping it now
I thought if anybody didn't do it who
was connected to Jeffrey Epstein it was
Alan dershowitz not because he's not a
man not because he doesn't have red
blood but because that guy is just so
buttoned up that guy is just so smart he
is so disciplined I just don't think he
would have opened himself up to
something like that for and all of the
other considerations
as well
this raises a question here
why is it why is it
that we don't know
who actually did it
why is I mean I guess we can strongly
suspect that prince Andrew did because
they settled for
reportedly millions of pounds out of
court
but why is it that okay dershowitz was
all in the headlines but now his accuser
says now I think I was mistaken
why is it that we don't have that little
black book
why is it why is it the keyline Maxwell
she's getting some slap on the wrist
and as part of her prosecution
we don't know who who was with Epstein
we know that this guy
we know He piled around with some of the
richest most powerful people on planet
Earth why is it that none of the people
who did have sex with the underage girls
why is it that they haven't been held to
account why is it that we don't even
have their names for certain
this is the sort of environment in which
someone like Trump really thrives and
there's a little bit of an irony here
because Trump did know Jeffrey Epstein
because Epstein was a member of his Club
but there has been no serious allegation
that Donald Trump went to creepypetto
island or that he slept with any of
these girls trust me if there were any
evidence of it the Democrats would have
been running with this for six years it
doesn't exist Bill Clinton took dozens
of flights with Jeffrey Epstein on the
Lolita Express you don't see any of
those same kind of allegations about
Donald Trump nothing
but this is the sort of environment in
which someone like a trump will flourish
and it's it's even now as I think he's
burning a lot of political Capital with
people who would otherwise support him
in these attacks on Ron DeSantis and
Glenn young and everyone else this is
still an advantage that Donald Trump has
that the other guys don't
Glenn young and especially Rhonda santis
they are incredibly good skilled
politicians who are
doing really excellent things and who I
think have a good clear political vision
and who have a lot of political courage
and a lot of political competence and
all the rest of it
but the distinguishing feature here is
Donald Trump even still even after
serving a term as president is not
viewed as a politician he did not work
in politics
all the other guys who potentially could
run are politicians and they've been
politicians and that's their profession
and good for them I think politics
actually can be a perfectly dignified uh
profession if one does it the right way
maybe that's a rare case but it
certainly can be but this is still
something that Donald Trump has and so
the more corrupt the more insane
the more nefarious that the political
establishment seems
the better Donald Trump looks and even
now even after everything that he has
been through
even after the bloom might be off the
rose a little bit that is still going to
be something that gives him a real shot
in 2024. the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss it okay
because this is fake headline Friday if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]